[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit niki
siren ihnen allen einen schönen
sonntagabend wir bringen sie in aller
kürze auf den stand der dinge natürlich
tut mir das auch sportlich und
ausbildung dort wo die zähne mit
eishockey zum beispiel guten abend dann
schauen wir jetzt gemeinsam auf die
themen die wir vorbereitet haben
kompromiss mit offenen fragen der
klimapakt von glasgow ist für die einen
ein aufbruchsignal für die anderen eine
enttäuschung
mehr home office mehr 3g die politik in
berlin will jetzt offenbar schnell auf
die rasant steigenden corona zahlen
reagieren
und lockdown beschluss in österreich ab
morgen dürfen ungeimpfte nur noch aus
dringenden gründen ihre wohnung
verlassen
bevor wir auf corona blicken zuerst zur
klimagipfel bilanz von glasgow der
fridinger future bewegung ist es
gelungen das internationale politik sich
viel stärker als zuvor mit klimaschutz
auseinandersetzt aber wie viel hat es
wirklich gebracht bei der konferenz mit
200 staaten es war will man schrittweise
aus der fossilen energie aussteigen aber
trotzdem ist da viel enttäuschung einige
reaktionen
der generalsekretär der vereinten
nationen gutes schwant unser
zerbrechlicher planet hängt am seidenen
faden
blablabla das ist die kurze twitter
zusammenfassung des gipfels von greta
team berg und dagegen meint der
britische premier johnson ist sei ein
großer schritt nach vorne marco über den
gemeinsamen gipfelbeschluss und das echo
der hammerschlag für den klimapakt von
glasgow er beendete auch das feilschen
und pokern um formulierungen bis zur
letzten minute auf indiens wunsch blieb
schließlich vom harten kohleausstieg nur
noch ein mildes herunterfahren ich hätte
mir eine stärkere sprache gewünscht ich
hätte mir gewünscht dass man das noch
etwas deutlicher formuliert aber das
historische ist es das erste mal in
einem dokument einer weltklimakonferenz
so etwas konkretes verankert ist das
ende des fossilen zeitalters
geklärt sind endlich auch die letzten
details des klima regelbuch sie sind
wichtig damit die umsetzung des vertrags
von paris in schwung kommt denn die
erderwärmung auf höchstens 1,5 grad zu
begrenzen
dieses ziel machten die länder der welt
in glasgow so deutlich wie nie noch
reichen die bisherigen zusagen aber
längst nicht aus es war ja hier die
missionen 1,5 grad in reichweite zu
halten ich sag mal in reichweite ist es
vielleicht nicht es ist immer noch in
sichtweite und das ist gut aber alle
staaten sind eigentlich hier
aufgefordert worden nach hause zu gehen
hausaufgaben zu machen im nächsten jahr
wieder dazu kommen mit besseren zielen
denn das was hier auf den tisch gekommen
ist reicht eben nicht um das pariser
klimaziel zu erreichen statt nur alle
fünf jahre müssen die nationalen
klimaziele ab jetzt jährlich
nachgebessert werden das ist neu und
zeigt was von glasgow bleiben wird vor
allem noch viel arbeit
klimaforscher und aktivisten kritisieren
dass glasgow ergebnis denn nach wie vor
werden wir bei 2,4 grad erderwärmung
landen auf der anderen seite es geht um
einen völkerrechtlichen vertrag daher
weiter verhandelt worden ist und da sind
sehr viele rechtliche und bürokratische
hürden abgebaut worden und das heißt
start frei für neue internationale
klimaschutzprojekte
also am ende haben sich die staaten der
welt bei den verhandlungen in glasgow
auf einen kompromiss geeinigt und wie
der genau aussieht und andere wichtige
beschlüsse zum kampf gegen die
erderwärmung lesen sie jederzeit bei uns
auf zdf heute
jetzt zu corona wie konnte es nur wieder
so weit kommen so oder so ähnlich fragen
sich das ja gerade viele millionen im
land immer lauter werden die rufe nach
massnahmen verschärfungen
spd-arbeitsminister heil will wieder
eine home office pflicht und dazu 3g am
arbeitsplatz einführen auch die ampel
parteien justieren wohl noch einmal nach
wir schauen ob die zahlen insgesamt
haben die korona infektionen in
deutschland die fünf millionen marke
überschritten das robert koch institut
meldet 33
1498 neuinfektionen binnen eines tages
das sind knapp 10.000 mehr als vor einer
woche 55 todesfälle kamen innerhalb von
24 stunden hinzu
die sieben tage instituts steigt erneut
weiter auf jetzt 2 189
so corinna situation und den plänen
jetzt nicole diekmann
das angebot zu klein denn die nachfrage
sehr groß im sächsischen pirna lasse
menschen sich boostern wie es heißt
holen sich ihre auffrischimpfung die
angst vor einer infektion geht um denn
hier explodiert die inzidenz noch
schneller als anderswo bundesweit die
lage dramatisch die ampel will jetzt
nachschärfen der bundesarbeitsminister
legt einen gesetzentwurf vor
dazu gehört dass wir konsequent 3 gegen
den betrieben durchsetzen das heißt es
der zutritt zu unternehmen nur für
geimpfte genesene oder getestete gilt
und das gehört auch dazu dass wir home
office wieder dort in kraft setzen wo
immer es möglich ist die lage auf den
intensivstationen spitzt sich weiter zu
fachleute schlagen alarm nun diskutiert
die ampel auch 3g in zügen damit und mit
den plänen von hubertus heil sind fdp
und grüne einverstanden letztere
erneuern zudem ihre forderung nach einer
impfpflicht das bedeutet aber auch dass
man jetzt prüfen muss für bestimmte
berufsgruppen gerade im
gesundheitsbereich gerade im
pflegebereich auch über verpflichtende
impfung nachzudenken doch all das geht
etwa dem bayerischen ministerpräsidenten
söder nicht weit genug zweig und masken
pflicht in der gastronomie und bei
veranstaltungen zweig plus in clubs
bayern verschärft ab dienstag die regeln
und nennt die von der ampel geplanten
wörtlich in jeder hinsicht unzureichend
gestolpert quasi mit kurzen hosen und
sommerreifen in einen eiskalten winter
es wird nicht funktionieren
in elf tagen haben fünfundzwanzigster
läuft die epidemische lage von
nationaler tragweite aus bis dahin noch
viel redebedarf in der ampel und
zwischen bund und ländern
schlimmer die korona situation in
unserem nachbarland österreich dort gilt
ab montag ein zehntägiger lockdown
bedeutet ungeimpfte ab zwölf jahren
dürfen dann nur noch aus dringenden
gründen das haus verlassen betroffen
davon ungefähr zwei millionen von knapp
neun millionen bürgerinnen und bürgern
in österreich über die ausnahme
situation und was sie bedeutet jetzt
britta hilpert
österreichs intensivstationen laufen
voll es sind fast nur ungeübte die hier
liegen landesweit lichdi sieben tage
incidence bei rund 815 tendenz steigend
es gibt bereits eine impfpflicht für
körpernahe dienstleistungen 3g am
arbeitsplatz zweig im gasthaus es reicht
nicht denn nur 65 prozent in österreich
sind geimpft deshalb nun der lockdown
für ungeimpfte ab morgen nur aus gutem
grund dürfen sie auf die straße da es
aber auch das ist die unterkante der
maßnahmen dass die gemeinsame
bundesweite maßnahme aber
selbstverständlich steht es natürlich
den bundesländern frei sowie das eine
zwischenzeit auch schon gehandhabt wurde
von mehreren weitere maßnahmen punktuell
zu setzen salzburg und oberösterreich
sind strenger sie haben in sidenten
sogar weit über 1000 auf
weihnachtsmärkten wird alkoholausschank
verboten die nacht gastronomie wird nun
geschlossen maßnahmen die auch geimpfte
treffen bei sehr hohen instanzen reicher
einen login für ungeimpfte nicht mehr
sagen virologie der zusatznutzen den man
erzielt wird wahrscheinlich nicht
ausreichen um in oberösterreich oder
salzburg die zahlen so drastisch nach
unten zu bringen wie es eigentlich
notwendig wäre es bilden sich nun wieder
schlangen vor den impfzentren aber die
meisten wollen den dritten stich die
hohe zahl an ungeimpften so fürchten sie
hier hat bald zur folge dass auch
geimpfte sich wieder einschränken müssen
heute ist volkstrauertag ein tag an dem
der kriegstoten und der opfer von
gewaltherrschaft gedacht wird
vertreterinnen und vertreter aller
verfassungsorgane nahmen an einer
kranzniederlegung an der neuen wache in
berlin teil in seiner anschließenden
rede im parlament erinnerte
bundespräsident steinmeier an den
deutschen vernichtungskrieg in ost und
südosteuropa der millionen zivilisten
zwangsarbeiter und kriegsgefangene das
leben kostete
wir machen jetzt mit sport weiter und
rudi und es gibt einen mannschaftserfolg
auf dem eis für deutschland dritter sieg
im dritten spiel die deutsche eishockey
nationalmannschaft der männer hat den
deutschland cup gewonnen im letzten
spiel des vier nationen turniers
besiegte das team von trainer toni
wiederholen die slowakei mit 4 zu 1
gelungene generalprobe für olympia
hellwach zeigte sich die deutsche
mannschaft dabei in ihrem letzten
turnierspiel nach 14 sekunden die
führung durch leo für eine
traumkombination des dbb teams wenig
später abgeschlossen durch toby reader
dass zwei zu null besser kann man solch
eine situation wohl nicht ausspielen und
doch muss die mannschaft im zweiten
drittel kurze zeit zittern bocek der
anschlusstreffer zum 2 1 für die
slowakei ein tor in überzahl durch
dominik bittner zum 3 2 1 und dann der
überragende tobi reader in diesem match
zum 4 1-endstand bescheren der deutschen
mannschaft nach 2015 endlich wieder ein
erfolg im heimischen deutschland kam
deutschlands eishockey frauen haben die
olympischen spiele erneut verpasst der 3
2-erfolg nach penaltyschießen gegen
dänemark reichte nicht aus um das ticket
nach peking zu lösen dazu wäre ein sieg
in der regulären spielzeit nötig gewesen
nach einem torlosen ersten drittel
verwandelt julia zorn in der 31 minute
einen abpraller von der bahn der
zuführung für das dbb-team lilly becker
erhöht kurz darauf auf 2 0
dänemark kämpft sich zurück erzählt noch
im zweiten drittel den anschlusstreffer
in der 48 minute der ausgleich im
penalty-schießen kapitänin zorn mit dem
entscheidenden treffer zum 3 2 sieg für
deutschland
dänemark holt mit dem 2 2 nach der
regulären spielzeit einen punkt den
turniersieg und damit das ticket für
peking
und das war es auch schon vom sport mit
vielen dank rudi wir schon fix auf die
wetter aussichten für morgen in
ostbayern und am östlichen alpenrand
länger sonnig sonst meist trüb aber
trocken höchstwerte zwischen 6 und 13
grad
ja so viel von uns ich empfehle ihnen
noch christian sievers 21.45 mit dem
heute-journal wünsche ihnen noch einen
angenehmen sonntag abend und morgen
einen guten wochenstart wir sehen uns
dann morgen abend um 7 wieder